oh look at that look at that stylish
lucky man lucky man
emma and i have always
loved each other really i walked into
the room where we were having tutoring
and i just don't know how to say it i
just fell in love with him emma watson
and tom felton finally addressed their
rumored romance
it feels kind of emotional actually it's
definitely intense we don't blame you
emma harry potter fans have been
standing this potential relationship for
years and the actors took the subject
head on and harry potter 20th
anniversary returned to hogwarts
[Music]
oh look at that look at that stylish
lucky man lucky man
emma and i have always
loved each other really while discussing
the teenage puppy love going around on
the set emma and tom took a moment to
set the record straight i think i was in
the hair makeup chair
and someone said something along the
lines of yeah she had a crush on you i
used to come in every day and look for
his number on the call sheet it was
number seven
and if
if his number was on the call sheet it
was an extra exciting day emma even
shared the moment she quote fell in love
with tom i walked into the room where we
were having tutoring the assignment that
had been given was to draw what you
thought god looked like and tom had
drawn a girl
with a backward cap
on a skateboard
and i just don't know how to say it i
just fell in love with him okay but did
their relationship ever blossom into
something more than friends it's kind of
a million dollar question it certainly
is which is why emma provided this very
clear answer
nothing has ever ever ever ever happened
romantically with us we just love each
other
that's all i can say about that
as they both explained this close
connection stayed platonic he was three
years above me and so for him he was
like
you're like my little sister
i was became very protective over her
yeah i've always had a soft spot for for
her um
and that continues to the day
i think really the truth of it was tom
was the one i could often be
more
vulnerable with there's always been
something that's like i don't know a
kinship tom and emma's comments follow
years of romance speculation about the
hogwarts alums including in 2019 when
they added new fuel to the rumors when
they were spotted spending time together
and after the sighting rupert grant
shared this interesting tidbit with e.t
about the two could you ever see the two
of them together yeah i could there was
always something you think so with the
spark
we are something if that makes any sense
as far as we've we've uh
we've been very close for a long time
and i i
adore her of course et also had to ask
tom himself about the rumored romance
when speaking with the actor last year i
think she's fantastic and hopefully she
returns the compliment but um
as far as the romantic side of it i
think that's a slytherin gryffindor uh
thing rather than a tom and emma thing
but um i i absolutely think the world of
her and i think um
i think being
part of what we've all been part of but
for her to be kind of the only
girl certainly the youngest one on set
to grow up with what she had to grow up
with was was incredibly exciting and
listen you're gonna get me teary now
[Music]
you